But the DMCA does allow some exclusions.
So, there are exclusions for
research and educational purposes.
So, if you're doing research in sort of
understanding how strong, secure some
anti-piracy techniques are, hopefully
you're not doing anything illegal.
Similarly, as I said,
libraries can make some
limited number of copies and
that's not viewed as illegal either.
So that's one of the exclusions.
However, I should say that,
one of the criticisms people have for
these laws is that they're
kind of vague and broad.
And people sort of have different
interpretations of those depending on
who they are.
So although we sort of say there
are exclusions, of course,
how far those exclusions go, there
have been disagreements about that.
So RIAA, which is the Recording
Industry Association of America,
they'll actually file lawsuits
against P2P sharing music.
So these are on one side, the
Electronic Frontier Foundation or EFF,
sort of what is about a too
broad a scope of these laws and
potential abuse of the laws themselves